good afternoon everyone thanks very much
for your patience while we were delayed
a little bit I have a few things to talk
about up top and then we'll get right to
your questions so first of all to add to
information already provided earlier by
the White House at the direction of the
president of the United States fighter
aircraft assigned to U.S Northern
command successfully took down a high
altitude Airborne object off the
northern coast of Alaska at 1 45 PM
eastern standard time today within U.S
Sovereign airspace over U.S territorial
water
on February 9 North American Aerospace
Defense command detected an object on
ground radar and further investigated
and identified the object using fighter
aircraft
the object was flying at an altitude of
40 000 feet and posed a reasonable
threat to the safety of Civilian flight
U.S Northern command is beginning
recovery operations now
U.S northern command's Alaska command
coordinated the operation with
assistance from the Alaska Air National
Guard
Federal Aviation Administration and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
we have no further details about the
object at this time including any
description of its capabilities purpose
or origin the object was about the size
of a small car so not similar in size or
shape
to the High Altitude surveillance
balloon that was taken down off the
coast of South Carolina on February 4.
separately U.S Northern command
continues their recovery operations in
support of the recent takedown of the
Chinese high altitude surveillance
balloon recovery teams have mapped the
debris field
and are in the process of searching for
it and identifying debris on the ocean
floor
debris that's been recovered so far is
being loaded onto vessels taken ashore
cataloged and then moved onwards to labs
for subsequent analysis and while I
won't go into specifics due to
classification reasons I can say that we
have located a significant amount of
debris so far that will prove helpful to
our further understanding of this
balloon and its surveillance
capabilities
of note due to less than favorable sea
States right now teams will continue to
conduct underwater survey and Recovery
as conditions permit the department
wants to thank our interagency partners
from the U.S Coast Guard the FBI and
state and local authorities for their
continuing assistance and partnership
uh in other news and I think this is
important uh that we remember a lot of
folks and uh people in turkey and Syria
right now are are suffering we want to
again express our support for the people
of turkey a and Syria as they respond to
the deadly earthquakes that struck there
earlier this week in support of ongoing
U.S assistance efforts spearheaded by
the U.S agency for International
Development U.S European command has
positioned Personnel equipment and a
range of assets to Aid the government of
turkey a and its continued search and
rescue efforts this includes the U.S
Navy's George H.W bush carrier strike
group repositioning to the Eastern
Mediterranean Sea to provide Logistics
medical and rotary airlift support if
required additionally U.S army rotary
Wing aircraft began flying missions out
of intralik air base in Turkey a on
February 7 to transport transport First
Responders to the most affected
populations and on February 8th uh-60
Blackhawks transported injured civilians
to a local medical facility U.S European
command has designated U.S naval forces
Europe and Africa as the lead component
command overseeing the ucom humanitarian
assistance and disaster relief efforts
within turkey
to Aid in that coordination U.S Marine
Corps Brigadier General Andrew Priddy
U.S Naval Amphibious forces Europe
commander and Second Marine
Expeditionary Brigade Commanding General
arrived in Turkey a February 9 to lead
military coordination coordination
efforts with U.S agencies involved in
the humanitarian Aid and disaster relief
efforts we'll continue to provide you
with updates as we receive them UConn
will be issuing a press release with
further details but again we offer our
thoughts and prayers to the people of
turkey a and Syria during this tragic
and difficult time
and finally secretary Austin welcomed
Canadian minister of National Defense
and on for a bilateral meeting here in
the Pentagon today the secretary
expressed his thanks and appreciation to
minister Anan for the cooperation
rendered by Canada and tracking the PRC
high altitude surveillance balloon that
violated the sovereignty of both of our
countries during the meeting both
leaders reaffirmed the close defense
relationship between the United States
and Canada and a readout will be
available later today on defense.gov and
with that I will take your questions
we'll start with Associated Press tarkov
hi thank you for doing this
um a couple of questions on this latest
shoot down first what type of U.S
fighter aircraft were used and what type
of munition did they fire and do you
already have Navy assets or Coast Guard
assets out in involved in a recovery
process and then I have a few more
thanks Tara so so the the aircraft that
took down the object was an F-22 flying
out of a Joint Base Elmendorf in Alaska
and employed an aim9x to to take down
the the object in terms of assets that
are currently involved
in terms of
recovery we have hc130 hh60 and ch-47
aircraft participating in that recovery
effort
okay you mentioned there was a
reasonable threat was there also a
threat to potentially this object
detecting some of our more sensitive
radar capabilities that are based in
Alaska and then what hasn't been said is
where this object has come from is there
any indication that this was also a
Chinese surveillance balloon object
whatever it is yeah so at this point uh
we don't know the origin of the object
again we will know more once we're able
to potentially recover some of those
materials but the primary concern again
was the potential Hazard to civil flight
and so again we'll know more later thank
you both perceived threat to any of the
radar installations that we have based
in Alaska again right now we'll we'll
know more once we assess it
um
let me just leave it at that thank you
Liz
thank you my question
um what made this threatening enough to
shoot down what is different about this
object than the last object that was
over Alaska because it was chosen not to
shoot the last one down over Alaska yeah
so you know the important thing to
understand here is anytime we detect
anything we're going to first of all
observe it and then make a decision and
take appropriate action so you have to
look at each individual case on its own
merits in this particular case given the
fact that it was operating at an
altitude that posed a reasonable threat
to civilian air traffic the
determination was made and the president
gave the order to take it down was there
a specific threat a specific civilian
air traffic incident that could have
happened again as you well know civilian
aircraft operate you know at a variety
of ranges up to 40 to 45 000 feet so
again there was a reasonable concern
that this could present a present a
threat to or a potential Hazard to
civilian air traffic so
has secretary Austin reached out to his
Chinese counterpart or any other
counterparts at all since this has been
tracked
since this particular object no
let me go here and then I'll come over
to Lauren
things from the previous balloon had
been recovered what additional
information you have now about the
capabilities of that balloon yeah so
we're continuing to assess that again
I'm not able to go into more detail
other than in addition to learning a lot
about the balloon and the capabilities
that it has while it was over the
continental United States we have
identified or located a significant
amount of debris on the ocean floor that
will be very beneficial to us learning
more about it but at this point in time
I'm not going to have more details
manufacturing label on these equipments
or the balloons indicate that they're
all manufactured in China sourced from
China again I'm not going to have
details to provide it at this point in
time
yeah 39 other countries have have
indicated they have seen balloons in
their in their territories are you
sharing those information from from the
Pentagon to these countries or the
capabilities how you shot them down so
in terms of what we're learning about
these balloons I know the state
department has talked to this in terms
of our International Outreach certainly
the Department of Defense plays a role
in those relationships and so we will
continue to work with our allies and
partners to share information along with
our state department colleagues let me
go to Warren
two questions first did this object show
any signs of maneuver maneuverability or
propulsion and then you and other
Pentagon officials made a big deal about
how much intelligence was gathered by
letting the other one float across much
of the United States and yet you shot
this one down before entered the United
States is that the Pentagon bowing to
political pressure was there nothing to
gain from this one yeah so so again uh
we're going to judge each of these on
its merits no indication at this time
that it was maneuverable but again we'll
we'll know more
um and in terms of entering the United
States it did enter U.S airspace and we
took it down
intelligence from this one as you did
from the previous one we're going to
recover uh what we can from this and
more to follow and was the decision to
shoot it down before it entered too far
to the U.S airspace the Pentagon bowing
to political pressure from the hill uh
look again we're going to judge each of
these objects on its own merits it
entered into U.S airspace on February
9th uh we we sent up aircraft to assess
what it was the decision was made that
it posed a reasonable threat to civilian
air traffic the president uh gave the
order to take it down and we took it
down thank you Laura and then I'll go to
Dan
um
oh I'm sorry thanks for taking my
question
um so a couple questions first of all
has anything like this happened before
with a object this size this shape in
this this particular
um
height for the 40 000 foot range has
that has it happened before and then
second of all
um how why did you can you say more
about why you knew the that last balloon
or object was from China whereas this
one you don't know
um so
in terms of this particular object again
as I highlighted we don't know where
it's from it posed a reasonable threat
to civilian air traffic and so the
determination was made to take it down
in terms of the other balloon as I
mentioned in our previous uh briefing we
have learned a lot about the Chinese
surveillance high altitude balloon
program we've we've gathered a lot of
information over the last couple of
years and so we were able to based on
that information detect at a very early
stage as it approached U.S airspace we
had a good understanding of what it was
as I mentioned we were able to monitor
that closely track it while it went over
the continental United States learn a
lot about it and take it down at the
appropriate time so would you would you
urge us to put this in a different
bucket than that or should we yeah I
think I was pretty clear this was
traveling at about forty thousand feet
which posed a potential a reasonable
threat to civilian air traffic and the
decision was made to take it down so Dan
when the pilot when the pilots
approached it
um and and they've determined I
understand that it was not manned how
did they determine that and at that
point wouldn't it be possible to at
least describe what they were looking at
did it resemble a balloon or an airplane
or what again we'll know more and have
more information once we've recovered
this I
will give credit to our Pilots that
they're very capable in terms of looking
at an object assessing whether or not
this had the potential to be manned at
that altitude something that small very
very unlikely that it was manned and so
again no indication that it was manned
presented presented a potential
reasonable threat to civilian air
traffic and we took it down what speed
was it traveling at by the way I don't
have that information and the Chinese
balloon if we could go back is it is it
still in the pentagon's view plausible
or maybe even likely that it was uh not
necessarily intentional when that
balloon turned and blew Eastward that
that it seemed to have not uh
you know lost some had some technical
problem yeah so Dan what I would tell
you is based on the information that we
have uh it was
being maneuvered and purposefully driven
along its track again recognizing that
winds do play a role because of the
maneuverability of the balloon it's our
assessment that this was a purposeful
mission in terms of the Chinese
motivations again I'd have to refer you
back to China to talk about that ma'am
and then come to Nancy
emailed you police body camera footage
showing a National Guard general in Ohio
pushing my colleague and having to be
escorted away from him this week we
asked the Ohio National Guard for
comment but do you as a spokesperson for
the Department of Defense condone such
conduct by a commissioned officer of the
U.S military against an American
journalist yeah so let me be clear the
answer is no that that's not acceptable
behavior the Secretary of Defense the
the Department of Defense absolutely
supports strongly supports a free and
independent press so again I'd refer you
to the Ohio National Guard for any
comments about that particular incident
but I can assure you that that is not
acceptable behavior face any kind of
conduct on becoming charge under the
ucmg yeah I'd have to refer you to them
I'm not going to uh
I'm not going to make those kind of
policy comments here from the podium in
terms of what they may or may but not be
doing to address it it would be
inappropriate for me to comment on that
let me go to Nancy
um I just had a couple clarifying
questions you said that um that the
pilots are able to see it that it wasn't
the same shape or size as the balloon
can you say definitively it was not a
balloon
um I don't at this point considering the
fact that we're still assessing the
object
um
I I don't want to get into
characterizing it um
so just leave it at that you mentioned
you know how fast I was traveling Kenny
safe was traveling faster or slower than
the balloon
I don't have that information from me so
I don't want to make it up
try a couple more um did anyone try to
within the administration contact their
Chinese counterparts before the decision
was made to shoot it down in terms of uh
when you say the administration if
you're referring to the White House I'd
have to refer you to them the Department
of Defense to my knowledge did not again
we don't know the point of origin of
this object
um so yeah and was there any effort to
jam or somehow disable this object
before so such that it would posed less
of a I I don't want to get into specific
tactics or techniques that we may or may
not use when observing these types of
things again
NORAD sent up aircraft to observe to see
what it was and then the ultimate
decision was made based on the
reasonable threat to civil civilian air
traffic to take it down so thank you
Tony
well thanks you mentioned you've
recovered uh recovered a significant or
located a significant amount of debris
is it fair to say you've said you've
looked at a significant amount of the
payload
you're talking about the PRC high
altitude balloons one today
um so Tony at this point
um
I'm not able to go into more detail
other than we've what I would describe
we've discovered or located a
significant amount of the uh the
debris associated with the balloon again
we'll have more details to follow but
I'll just leave it at that located but
you haven't recovered and took uh pulled
out of the ocean for forensic analysis
is that right yeah so great point so the
way that uh the way to understand how
this is is unfolding is as we map out
the area where the debris field would be
it enables us to to figure out where the
places that we need to prioritize a
search recognizing that we're talking a
wide area and so as that happens divers
are able to go down and depending on the
size of the debris they're able to tag
it so debris that can be brought up
quickly is brought up put on a vessel
taken ashore debris that's going to take
more time and again especially given the
current sea States it may take a little
longer we know where it is so we tag it
and then we'll go back and eventually
recover all of that and bring it up the
equivalent is you found the Titanic but
you don't you haven't started pulling up
the debris yet from it exactly when I
ask you about the overall program you
said you've been you been learning a lot
about this balloon program over the last
couple years yet the annual China report
doesn't have a peep above balloons in
there you spend a lot of money and
effort but no balloons we learned about
Taiwan and China's balance of power
against them and satellites and jets but
no balloons why not
so so Tony what I would say on the on
the unclassified China Power report
right there's going to be certain
elements uh intelligence aspects in the
unclassified version that may not be
included in that particular report in
terms of what's in that report and
what's not in that report again we can
go back and look at that but I can tell
you I can assure you that there are a
lot of activities that we continue to
monitor to include this balloon program
and we've learned a lot over the last
couple years but the classified version
balloons in there I'd have to go back
and look I do not know the answer to
that thanks let me get a couple other
folks here Mike and then
the only reason the American people know
about the first balloon is because a
couple of guys in Montana spotted it in
the leaked out my question is if it has
remained secret and did not become a
spectacle and be an arguably an
embarrassment to the White House would
you have shot it down or allowed it to
continue on its way
so you're asking me to speculate
so so Mike I'll kind of just push back a
little bit at the assertion there uh so
first of all again what made this
balloon different was the length and
duration uh that it was over the United
the continental United States look we
track activities all over the globe on a
daily basis
um
some of which will remain classified
because again we don't want to reveal
sources and methods and this particular
case
um I can tell you uh that there were
efforts underway to uh to make that
public I you know Montana journalists
reporting notwithstanding
um all that to say look there are going
to be times when there's activities
happening that we're monitoring that
we're we're not going to go public
especially if it doesn't present a
particular or pose a significant threat
to the American public but again uh as
as we monitored that balloon there was
an effort underway to ensure that that
folks understood what this was
especially given how visible it was
um and I'll just stop there thank you
yes ma'am
thank you General first a really quick
follow-up on Tony's question at this
point is the Pentagon reassessing the
need for counter balloon or counter
object capabilities at that altitude at
this time
so so what I would tell you is not you
know in the Air Force sometimes we talk
about don't get platform specific right
so what we're talking about is
monitoring the domain and having domain
awareness and again as I highlighted uh
it seems like a couple days ago probably
last week we're continuing to learn more
more about this program which enables us
to identify and track objects and so uh
and and thus ensure that we're
continuing to protect uh our skies and
our airspace thank you and then
um real quick first do you and Admiral
Kirby know the shape of this new object
and if so what is um sort of the reason
for why you can't share its shape before
it was shot down and then separately how
is the recovery efforts of this new
object downed over ice different from
the one downed over the coast in water
and are you guys using unmanned systems
for this new object as well yeah thank
you so in terms of the shape I don't
know I have not seen any imagery of it
I'm just telling you the verbal
characteristics as it was described to
me in terms of the difference in the
recovery effort I mean again so this
literally was what an hour and a half
two hours ago so that's underway right
now uh so more to follow on that front
um right now I think they're moving to
the site we'll have more to follow in
the days ahead let me go to a few other
folks here sorry
some new folks back here and then we'll
go over here to Mike
okay you mentioned that uh the object
was spotted yesterday is that the first
that you that we saw it
or did we see it coming in a couple days
before no it was spotted yesterday and
uh for uh follow-up uh did what we have
what we learned about the first balloon
last week did that help us detect this
object
um I would say that again we detect when
we detect objects
um
let me just back up so what you're
asking is did what we learned from the
PRC balloon help us track this kind of a
little bit of apples and oranges right
in terms of
NORAD and North com maintains the
ability to to track objects so again
they track this as it approached and
entered into U.S airspace
again we're still assessing what this
object was so
um I I don't know that we learned
anything new as a result of that other
than again I think we're all
to include the media and the public very
attuned to balloons at the moment so
thank you yes sir
thank you sir and uh just to clarify so
this was first identified when it flew
into U.S airspace is that correct or was
it identified before it it was detected
yesterday and then again uh NORAD sent
up aircraft to observe it see what it
was and then the decision was made to
take it down and do you have any
information whether this object flew
over any other Sovereign Nations or
countries I do not
have time for a few more let me go to
Joe
question about the recovery effort I
think you mentioned at the outset that
it that it was going to involve rotary
Wing aircraft that's because it landed
on ice as opposed to water that's why
there's an um watercraft being used is
it yeah Joe we'll get you more
information on that front
um you know again this happened just a
short while ago and so according to to
North com these are the assets that were
being used to go out and and do the
initial recovery but we'll have more
information in terms of the the various
roles and responsibilities of those just
uh get down on the weights for a second
any idea what um what units are involved
in the recovery effort or in the um the
F-22 that shot it down we can get you
that information thanks Phil
hey there just a couple clarification
questions first off when you first
identified it was a traveling at the
same altitude around 40 000 feet um did
you at that point know its velocity and
and secondly you know does doesn't
northcom have the authority on its own
to shoot down unidentified objects
entering U.S airspace if they pose a
threat to civilian air traffic and if so
then why was the president's
authorization uh required in this case
yeah thanks
um so my understanding is it was at
forty thousand feet when it was detected
and ultimately taken down uh the NORAD
uh North com Commander
um
does not have the authority necessarily
to take down an object if it's not
posing a potential hostile uh intent or
actions however given the fact that this
aircraft was uh up or excuse me this
object was operating at an altitude that
posed a reasonable threat to civilian
air traffic after consultation uh the
with the secretary and the president of
course the president uh on our advice uh
gave the order to take it down and we
took it down
I want to clarify is his authorization
required in a situation like this
um again it's kind of a moot point at
this point because the president gave
the order but he has the authorization
to take action against anything that
presents a potential threat to the
American public or people on the ground
in this particular case it was
determined that this posed a reasonable
threat to air traffic again I yeah I'll
just leave it at that thanks
Tara
just a couple of clarifiers
um was it a single F-22 or a pair that
were up today for the shot and then when
the when NORAD sent the initial aircraft
up to sea was there any sort of hailing
or any type of warning given typically
when an aircraft makes an incursion into
protected airspace there's a whole lot
of procedures that have to be followed
before it would escalate to something
like this okay well this was an object
right so it wasn't an aircraft per se
and to answer your earlier question it
was a two ship of f-22s but one aircraft
took the shot got time for one more go
to the Liz
uh really quick when it was started to
be tracked last night were you able to
tell what direction it was coming from
uh this this was traveling in a
northeasterly direction uh when it was
taken down and then one more um the
aircrafts that were observing it what
what type of aircrafts were those
I'll have to come back to you and I
think I know but I don't want to make it
up from the podium so we'll come back to
you on that one okay thank you very much
everybody I appreciate it